hey guys Pete here today's Game of
Thrones Season 8 video will be an
episode 5 preview and thoughts about
where things are headed got some new
photos from HBO we've had more time to
think about what happened in episode 4
and we've had more time to digest the
few scenes that we saw in the trailer
unfortunately for people who don't like
spoilers there's a lot of chatter about
potential leaks going around I've been
seeing a lot of comments in the videos
I've had some requests from viewers to
ask for you to not do that and I would
appreciate it myself I have no judgment
if you want to look at leaks and wonder
if they're correct or not then that's
fine but some people don't and when you
post up in the comments they see it and
that bothers them so be respectful
obviously I see that stuff because I
delete the comments some of it looks
like it might be right some of it looks
like it's crazy it's not gonna influence
how I make my videos and I think that's
all there is to say about that so let's
get into the video and speculate about
what might happen in the next episode so
last week I made of what's next video
and I talked about how I thought things
might end after we found out that the
night king was defeated in episode 3 I'm
gonna pick up from there
based on what we saw in episode 4 and
the new material that's out that we can
look at it does look like we're setting
up for the clash of Queens
Cersei is positioned to hold King's
Landing and Daenerys is in position to
take it away from her what I'm most
interested in in this episode though is
the stuff that's going to happen before
the actual battle this is an 80-minute
episode and and I don't think that the
battle itself will take that long maybe
half when all said and done so I think
there's gonna be a lot of other stuff
happening plus we know because jon said
that it would take about a fortnight for
him to march down that there's about two
weeks in between the time they left
Winterfell and when everyone will arrive
and the battle will be ready to begin
Cersei is positioned to get ended in
Episode five I think her executing
Masson day created a situation that
there is no possibility of her walking
out of this confrontation alive in last
week's video I said I thought she would
need to up her position by getting a ha
did your having someone turned to her
side of things in order to make her end
a bit more compelling but that doesn't
look like it's gonna happen and last of
the Starks we saw Jamie Lee Brienne and
head back towards Cersei I talked about
this in more detail in my episode for
questions video so you can watch that if
you want more but I do believe he's
actually going back to be with her like
the director of the episode said not
heading to King's Landing to kill her I
think he's the hooded character we see
entering the city and the shot of the
golden company from the trailer which
would mean that he will be able to get
to her I could be wrong about that being
him but I do think he's still the most
likely candidate of being a character we
care about being on her side for lack of
a better term of course I think there's
a good chance he'll change his mind and
could possibly end up killing her I've
been saying that for a long time but I
think him just being there and us caring
about that is what we're seeing unfold
as far as her getting a hostage or
someone becoming a traitor I think that
what we saw developed with Varys in the
last episode doesn't leave much room for
that Eris and Tyrion are the most likely
candidates to change alliances in an
episode four we found out that Varys is
a traitor
to Daenerys but he's moving to support
John and that makes a lot more sense
than him supporting Cersei Tyrion we saw
him plead with her before she killed my
Sande he seems to be more set up for
making a mistake by trying to keep her
alive rather than actually working with
her as for a hostage I don't think
that's really in the cards at this point
either there was a time when I thought
maybe she would get a hold of John and
we did get this photo that was released
Varys and John on a beach they could be
going to King's Landing it doesn't look
exactly like Dragonstone to me but we
also have photos of John out front on
the battlefield so I don't think that's
going to happen I think it is set up to
be a showdown between Daenerys and
Cersei
I think the wild-card is that she has
brought all the small folk into the red
keep some people think there might be
wildfire in there as well based off this
image with the barrels this may make it
tough for Daenerys to get to her but we
do have all these people who are trapped
going to King's Landing the hound aria
and Jamie who could get access to Cersei
and take care of business since we
brought up Varys it should be said that
I don't think he's gonna live through
this episode I think if he approaches
John and tells him he wants him to rule
then that's gonna be bad for him plus
he's already told Tyrion I think somehow
or other his disloyalty is going to come
out and Daenerys is probably gonna have
to deal with him before the battle even
begins for John I think it's pretty
clear what his endings gonna be now I
made a video a couple days ago about
that about him leaving King's Landing
and probably ended up in the real north
after I put that video out I read a
really good article about the same thing
written by Joanna Robinson from Vanity
Fair where she went
much deeper than I would be able to into
the Lord of the Rings parallels and at
this point I really do think that's
going to be the end of John's story
however that doesn't really say anything
about what he's gonna do in episode 5
what's he gonna do in this battle I
think he has to play a big part in that
but it's hard to see where that comes
from
I mean is he gonna kill the golden
companies Harry Strickland in combat on
the field like maybe but do we care
about Harry Strickland not really we
haven't even really been introduced to
him yet
so yes I do expect him to be out there
fighting I imagine that he will fight
valiantly like he always does perhaps he
can do something to save the common
people that might be collateral damage
but it's really hard to say what he'll
actually do in this battle that will be
in line with his character for Daenerys
they've set up the scenario where
everything has been stripped away from
her she's down to one dragon and we see
from this photo that she is probably
gonna go through some low moments in the
lead-up to the battle I still think
she's going to die before the end of the
story I just can't let go of that idea
but it's also very clear that she's
gonna have to make a decision about
taking the throne or stepping back and
giving up what she wants what she
believes that she deserves for the
greater good I hope that she makes the
right choice everything is completely
stacked
Esther at this point and I think a lot
will ride on what happens before or like
what we see go down beforehand as I
mentioned in my questions video her
getting pregnant doesn't seem as likely
as it did at the end of season 7 I do
think we'll have some moments with John
and Daenerys where we see them work
through what's going on as far as him
having a better claim but at least what
we've seen so far this season I don't
see them coming out of the end of
episode 5 as a couple I could be wrong
but I just don't see that they've been
pushing in that direction
Arya should be arriving in King's
Landing not long after John arrives I
still don't think it's very likely that
she's gonna cross Cersei off her list
considering that she already killed the
knight King I do think that we'll
probably see her take someone's face and
use that to get in close
get inside King's Landing they haven't
really used that this season and a lot
of build-up for that so I think that
we'll probably see that happen I'm not
sure who's or what's I just know that
I'm going to be like any scene that's
inside of King's Landing I'm gonna be
like is that Arya is that Arya the Hound
will also be there of course I think he
will end up confronting his brother and
they will have their one-on-one battle
it does make sense that is one of the
characters motivating factors at least
in the show and the mountain is Circe's
protector so I do believe that those two
will square off on Cersei side we also
have Euron and the golden company the
golden company just really seems like
bodies to me at this time you know like
she needed an army she got an army I'm
not sure if there's really anything
that's going to come of that except for
they're gonna fight for her side Joran
will die I think I don't think there's
many paths for him to get out of here a
lot of people think that him and his
fleet will get burnt by drogon because
he killed Rhaegar it makes sense we did
see that shot in the trailer so there's
definitely a good possibility of that
but I also think that Yara would want to
take him out of given the chance we
don't know if she'll show up for this
battle but if she does I think that
would be a good end
if she gets to take him out another
thing that people have been asking and
commenting about is there being more
dragons this is not something that
occurs to me at all like I think that
the position that Daenerys is in is
whether she wants to use the dragon she
has to take out King's Landing or not
having more dragons doesn't really solve
that problem it just makes her more able
to destroy the other side so I don't
think there's any chance we'll see any
other dragons I think that they made it
pretty clear that the forces are equal
here so they have a bunch of
anti-aircraft she has a dragon they have
about the equal number of forces Cersei
has the castle that's to her advantage
like I said there is a lot of ballista
but it's kind of joked about it in the
trailer breakdown but I didn't come out
that way I guess I think she can just
take the dragon really high in the air
and then swoop down like and avoid all
of that so I think it's like she can
destroy King's Landing if she wants she
has to make the decision of whether or
not to do that as far as the other
characters in the north's brand Sansa
Brienne bran seems happy to set it out I
don't think that he will play any part
in this episode at all
Sansa I think will stay in the north I
don't think we'll see her arrive in
King's Landing in episode 5 it's
definitely possible for the episode
after but I don't think those characters
will play a big part in episode 5 BN
could come to the capital after Jaime
but I don't think it's likely
I think she's sworn an oath to protect
Sansa she is there their army is not so
I think that that's her place I imagined
that when Jaime left she made peace with
the fact that that's what he wanted to
do as he wanted to go back to Cersei so
I don't expect her to play a part in
this either so the stage is set we have
two queens both have had everything they
love taken away for the most part
Circe's lost all of her children
Daenerys has lost two of her children
she's lost the man that she loved for
the most part he's still there but the
relationships on the rocks
she had her trusted advisor and closest
friend beheaded in front of her at the
end of the last episode there
is scheming against her behind her back
so it all comes down to how Cersei gets
removed and what Daenerys decides to do
as far as taking the Iron Throne
through fire and blood or sacrificing
that goal for the lives of all those
people that Cersei put in between them I
think this episode will end when they
kill Cersei I'm not a hundred percent
sure how that's gonna go down Jaime
could kill her
Daenerys could kill her I don't think
that Euron will be anywhere near her so
I don't think he's gonna be the one to
do it I'm curious to see how Jon plays a
part in the battle itself interested to
see what goes down with Daenerys and her
advisers before the battle kicks off and
definitely wondering if Cersei has
something up her sleeve
as a final Fu if she's about to die so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments this is the second last episode
of Game of Thrones that there will ever
be
I think episode six will likely be the
cleanup and then they'll figure out
who's gonna rule how it's going to be
ruled we'll probably see some of the
characters go away
perhaps Arya definitely John and we'll
find out how Westeros will exist going
on into the future so let me know what
you think in the comments please like
the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already I appreciate you guys watching
thank you for that I will talk to you
soon